I
how can it happen if tomorrow the
rain continues to fall
Bastien and the game is interrupted in
your game starts and I
interrupted several times
it's terrible no but it's crazy
what is happening  pass it's an incredible
for things to move there will have to
be an awareness live
today the the stadiums covered the
in the grand slams in this stand up
what and not the apart from sometimes you also have to
know how to modernize to
not being left
behind the competition is there between
the grand slams it's the perpetual transformation
[Applause]
thanks to our turn to lavish this
will all be history and we can
drive the matches to their conclusion
[Music]
[  Applause]
short delay 6 die
the smash
in the eye
and is suspended until
when repeating
a stoppage it always trades going
really or right or wrong
so it changes the shape of a match
damn not one  don't be a few
years younger than me and maybe if this
match was extended on Monday evening
he would have come out on top
because I was in good physical shape
and I still hold them
the next day  is always a
match who is who and which is painful
for the two boys because it is
players who know each other well who like each other
and then yes when this
match is extended because of the
night which sets in  when I see this
situation happen and obviously I the
months I lived it so it has me it
brings back memories I imagine a
little bit what they can live in
their in their head make them get back
into the game psychologically  and it's
extremely painful for a player all the more
in the east in the east in
the big meetings when we
approach the half cards and the
finals of care of the grand slam
ok
[Applause]
after j  must have been a lot a lot
of emotion in the stadium my  is really
on this ground so full full of good
memories here
finally roland garros we will be able
today that is to say it
's ancient history the players to
play their match from the first to the last
point
without almost any ban
[Music]
[Applause]
I think of them as an audience
of fairly wise people who respect the
traditions of the spirit of the game who
come here to experience emotions and
we want to satisfy these people I'm coming,
we want to continue to  in inverted commas
it's very frustrating for people who are
passionate about tennis who come to see
their greatest champions and
finally at 9 p.m. the match is interrupted
by night or at 7 p.m. by the rain
it's almost dramatic sometimes
having to tell people I'm sorry
but there won't be any you won't see
tennis have seen at roland garros it's
terrible for these people when ward
when you love sport and when you're
caught by parra match
on watch  ant of tournaments I like that
the next match can go
like this people have the opportunity to
enjoy the best women's
and men's matches
once again it's reassuring to
leave the locker room and that's to say
whatever  it's coming my match will
move to discuss until its end
finally this roof is there so we can not
only please the 15000
people on this philippe chatrier court
but also all the tennis fans who
follow the tournament on television
finally to see  a continuous match
without interruption and that really I
think that's the good news before
we had already had renovations
screen
but things are changing so fast that
here we had to do this
kind of work so direct central
it's  is really the final touch and
a hell of a final today we
are in phase iv so of these of these
works finally this case is the delivery
of him short philippe
chatrier how we often say it is  st our
flagship this is where everything is going to
happen this is where the final is obviously being played
so this is the most important building in
the project with the technology that exists
today to be able to provide a
continuous show guaranteed i  would say it
becomes something which is which as is
essential it was quite
normal for it to come to roland garros
we remember that work
began three years ago on this site
to finally bring this last
piece worried presses the icing on the
cake we are extremely proud
today to have this retractable roof
which is
magnificent  pieces one hundred and five meters long
including only rezaï and parents 105 m
from italy and students born in several
pieces in seven pieces in the shape of a
wing and then these pieces including the
assemblies and welding them on p  lace
including equipping them with the coverings of the
engines etc on site so there were
two manufacturing workshops and then
there were two towers to mount
each wing on the roof so each one
weighs 350 tonnes so we had
smoothing towers which  could carry a
load of 600 tons and therefore we were
on a rate of about 3 to 4 weeks
between each wing so it was a
technological feat of arrival
precisely it seemed to be right behind
us to mount them one by one on this
profile  chatrier at the beginning it was very
impressive but after two or
three years nice is easy instructor
finally but it was easy because it
was very very well studied before and
well organized we had a month ahead
of schedule
we hoisted the last lll number 11
with a month in advance when you see
the drawing hargitay key mounting digital
aids is what's there now
it's exactly the same
the specifications have been perfectly  t
filled out by the company
so to test on you and it
had to be made to work one so
indeed our concern was
4000 tonnes moving in
how it's going to behave
is it going to be noisy is
that  going to be stressful what it's going to be
disturbing at first we had we had a
lot of vibration problems it
vibrated a little we have a feeling
it was comfort it wasn't
solidity 1 it's comfort but good and
finally the technicians found
the roof it is it is controlled the
speed is controlled there are sensors
everywhere so that that the two motors
run at the same speed as the motors
in front they go faster than the
return motors behind so we have simplified
a little bit and we will find the
solution for the sensors no [ __ ] not
too much the engines for whom if not to live so that
they can advance the sport
so that this movement they are flexible
silent discreet so that the public does not
we don't notice anything we really have no
noise when this roof they those who
move it even surprised us 1 it's
stunning
but we operated it from the
console of the doors etc and on the fixed wings
so we were in  high with the guys we
piloted the roof directly from up there
it is indeed important to raise
especially after having light it is
completely dissociated the light of the
mobile roof
it is really two independent things
we can close the mobile roof  without
turning on the light we can turn on the
light without operating the roof
we have to light up
soon we will be able to start the tournament
at 8 o'clock in the morning and finish 19 years old not
as good guy classic schedules
every day we will see  matches at
night so it will allow me to put
into practice and test our our
light systems ratified they are
extremely efficient last week
for example we tried for the
first  time and light with
players on the field
well already carved out a place
afterwards we will put it online a
staging of the light on the spot ok I'll
call you
they put it on it's always stressful is
what the guys are going to be able to  play and
not in the face when they
serve or when they go up to approach
the professional player it goes very
quickly so there has to be good
lighting is efficient we have to
provide the best conditions
when we see the speed  how the
players evolve on the field to the
violence of their strikes
they need to have
exceptional light conditions and I believe
they are it goes by quickly
it's part of the lights was
part of phase 4
but not  so we all anticipated not
equipped all the ancillary courts simone
mathieu suzanne lenglen cast
light to be able to finish on all the
courts shed light on the others
for these facts to finish the matches there
for pale  rm and the next day what
nick turning on the light for a match that
in five sets but that ends at ten years old
but tonight to finish it and what we
do wrong it's decided we don't go out here anymore
and it's valid  also aside here 2280
as it is a little less of a race
between our side we feel a little my
opinion players will do a lot more
against on the 14 here when we see
the other grand slams especially the
intense strain open renovated as much
to question and see that roland is
doing the same thing
me i think that i think it's great
because it's interesting
to try to project oneself precisely on
evening matches at roland garros his
quest always our lot to do this  a
little bit different when we play at the
end of the day and there to be able to finish
at night actually it will
promise quite intense matches
emotionally
it's going super nice for the spectators
[Music]
so we must not stop we must
continue  at work  iller permanently
seek by all means
today to welcome fans
journalists from all over the world who are
only the echoes of what is happening here
because I believe that the hangar where
it is a great showcase for the
for  sport and French sport in
particular of which we are very proud
to have this tournament here in paris fayyad has
no others like that it's a work
of art it's everyone at their own stage and
that's very special  anyway
since from the greenhouses to the bottom
of the princes passing by court
philippe
chatrier well it is a fabulous stadium there was
no way to take
there was still an old tournament
aging and which distanced itself from
the others  or modernize and
transform the stadium
so in fact there was no plan b
with a plan to it was pre-chosen by
the federation
it's funny because we say to ourselves we say to ourselves that
we are in the same place and  at the same
time elsewhere I think that this stadium
since I  know there is there
it has transformed it has evolved and so
today here it is a pride and we
have to now discover all this
beautiful stadium to all the populations
that we are going to welcome to the next tournament
here are the roots of the  game at roland garros
were born here they stayed here so
from an emotional point of view
it's something rich and we have
to do with all that that's good too
the wooden poles to be back  in its
place and tradition and now it's
here that it will write history here and
today I am I am
tournament director and I have seen them grow up
change metamorphose and yes today we have
we have all  to the federation a lot a
lot of pride precisely every day to
be here